quand j'étais petit alors que mes
copains rêvé d'être policier pompier ou
mêmes astronautes
je rêvais d'être entrepreneur je disais
chef de travail comme mon papa
en effet mon père était entrepreneur et
mes deux grands pères était entrepreneur
et j'imaginais alors l'entreprise comme
un endroit extraordinaire où l'on crée
des produits et des services pour
améliorer la vie des gens
- f s'éloigne avec mon parcours scolaire
qui fut plutôt douloureux et je me suis
retrouvé en bep productique destiné à
être ouvrier d'usiné mais à 16 ans
j'intègre le monde du travail en
alternance
enfin du concret je me sentais beaucoup
plus à l'aise et quand j'ai eu 20 ans
mon oncle me demande est-ce que tu rêve
toujours de devenir entrepreneur et là
ce fut le déclic
oui j'en rêvais toujours à 22 ans je
démarre donc mon entreprise
une petite usine de marquage industriel
installé à brioude dans la haute loire
alors comme tout début d'activité
c'est aussi difficile que passionnant
mais avec mon équipe on prend déjà tous
beaucoup de plaisir dans cette aventure
en mode survie pendant les deux
premières années on va à l'essentiel
pas le temps pour les réunions les
objectifs les règles et méthodes etc
seule l'envié de bien faire conter
résultat la troisième année on est lancé
tellement bien lancé que l'on va doubler
notre chiffre d'affaires et prendre une
place dominante sur le marché
alors on se développe et on investit
dans la construction de notre première
usine et de machines automatiques
à ce moment là on change de dimension
et tout bascule je ressens une forme de
pression générale des conseils qui
fusent de toutes parts avec toujours le
même refrain
attention si tu veux pérenniser son
entreprise il faut mieux se structurer
mettre en place des méthodes de travail
alors sur le moment ça me semble logique
j'organise l'entreprise avec un chef
d'atelier des règles des méthodes des
process des contrôles bref que du fun
mais seulement au fur et à mesure que
nous devenions une vraie entreprise
l'ambiance se dégrade la magie se perd
pour ma part je prends moins de plaisir
à travailler je commence même à stresser
jusqu'à en avoir la boule au ventre
c'est l'étrange sentiment de devenir
dépendant des résultats financiers de
l'entreprise sur lesquels je suis
maintenant jugé par mes confrères par
les banques et même par mon équipe et
cette pression me pousse à une fuite en
avant où il faut faire toujours plus
sans surprise c'est une mauvaise année à
ce moment là j'ai 25 ans et l'entreprise
ne me fait plus du tout rêver
or si mon rêve de petit garçon était
bien de devenir chef de travail
implicitement j'aspirais aussi à être
heureux et là il faut reconnaître que ce
n'était pas le cas
donc un matin je vais l usine décidé à
leur expliquer mon mal être
je ne voyais que deux alternatives soit
vendre l'entreprise soit remettre à plat
fondamentalement tous nos modes de
fonctionnement alors ils ont été un peu
surpris mais surtout soulagé j'avais
enfin compris que ça n'allait pas notre
structuration pour ressembler à une
vraie industrie n'a pas du tout eu
l'effet recherché alors que notre
spontanée bienveillance avait fait ses
preuves pendant nos premières années
nous avons donc décidé de supprimer
toute cette complexité et nos premières
réflexions collectives nous ont amenés à
penser que deux axes devait devenir
prioritaire tout d'abord satisfaire les
besoins fondamentaux du collectif et
ensuite repenser la mission de
l'entreprise alors vis-à-vis des besoins
fondamentaux
nos décisions ont principalement porté
sur l'environnement de travail
quel rythme de travail voulons-nous
quels outils souhaitons nous mettre en
place quelle liberté
souhaitons-nous avoir et nous avons
listé toutes les contraintes que nous
pouvions supprimer vis-à-vis de la
mission de l'entreprise d'après vous
quel est le but d'une entreprise faire
plus de bénéfices
avoir plus de croissance
et bien pour nous ce n'est pas de gagner
toujours plus ce n'est pas non plus la
croissance à tout prix mais simplement
d'améliorer nos produits et les services
que nous offrons en améliorant notre
façon de travailler
penser en terme de bénéfice de
croissance d'embûches
c'est mettre la priorité sur des
résultats et cela ne constitue en aucun
cas à nos yeux un objectif nous en
avions fait la démonstration
alors pour ne pas nous fier à notre
seule intuition
je fais quand même des recherches sur
les entreprises ayant des modes de
fonctionnement différent je suis
incroyablement surpris de découvrir que
la plupart des entreprises qui sortent
du lot et qui me font rêver ont des
modes de fonctionnement atypique où
l'entrepreneur ne joue pas seulement un
rôle de dirigeant mais apporte un sens
profond à son action comme le disait si
bien antoine de saint-exupéry si tu veux
construire un bateau nous rassemble pas
tes hommes pour leur donner des ordres
pour leur expliquer chaque détail pour
leur dire où trouver chaque chose si tu
veux construire un bateau fait naître
dans le coeur de teom le désir de la mer
et ça ça a du sens j'aimerais maintenant
partager avec vous quelques exemples qui
illustrent nos principales remise en
cause comme la dernière fois que j'ai
fait un recrutement par exemple j'ai
choisi une personne tout à fait
compétente mais son intégration ne fut
pas extraordinaire l'équipe me demande
alors est-ce qu'on peut essayer de faire
notre propre recrutement
la différence c'est qu'ils ont choisi
une personne avec qui il se voyait bien
travaillé et du coup ils ont été
beaucoup plus patient et pédagogue dans
son intégration
le résultat fut juste stupéfiants en
quelques mois nous avions un nouveau
membre de l'équipe à part entière
j'avais aussi parfois tendance à penser
à leur place à ce qui était bon pour eux
et je me suis investi à fond pour leur
installer une salle de pause avec un
coin repas un peu à la google
je me disais ça va forcément leur plaire
mais étrangement je ressentais peu
d'engouement de leur part alors j'ai
insisté sans comprendre et je leur
demande mais que voulez-vous vraiment et
là ils me disent vouloir garder nos
canapés et simplement changé la table
basse en voulant bien faire
j'allais créer une frustration alors non
seulement ils ont changé la table basse
mais en plus ils me l'ont offerte une
magnifique table basse avec le logo de
l'entreprise forgée dans l'atoll comme
vous le savez chaque erreur nous fait
grandir et un matin très tôt
ils ont chargé dans la machine de la
résine tueur à la place de la résine
souple
résultat deux jours de production non
conformes
environ cent mille pièces quand l'équipe
se rend compte de l'erreur je suis en
week end et bien sans me consulter
ils ont pris l'initiative de dédommager
financièrement clients pour sa perte de
production d'annuler leurs vacances de
noël et de lui garantir une livraison
dans les temps pour assurer le lancement
produit le plus incroyable c'est que
j'en ai été informé par le client
lui-même il n'en revenait pas alors que
pour l'équipe c'était naturel
et finalement notre plus importante non
conformités fut aussi notre plus belle
expérience client à l'opposé il se
trouve que sur nos quelques 900 clients
il y en avait tant avec qui les échanges
étaient toujours compliqué et qui malgré
tous nos efforts restent insatisfaits ce
client représenter environ 15 % de notre
chiffre d'affaires mais 90% notre stress
ça vous parle alors on cherchait à
nouveau une solution et ils m'ont envoyé
expliquer aux clients notre
incompréhension trouvait avec lui
comment mieux travailler ensemble
je vous laisse imaginer la scène où
j'explique aux clients nos problèmes de
stress sa réponse a été mais je
travaille c'est comme ça c'est normal ce
n'est pas mon problème
nous avons donc décidé d'arrêter de
travailler avec lui alors cette année là
on a fait moins de chiffre d'affaires et
on a fait moins de bénéfices mais qu est
ce qu on a été heureux
finalement nous avons incroyablement
améliorer notre qualité de vie et cela
nous a renforcés sur le fait que la
santé doit toujours rester notre
priorité
alors maintenant vous vous dites
peut-être qu'il manque quelque chose
d'important le plaisir au travail c'est
bien mais quand on pense travail on
pense aussi rémunération et cela peut
être une source de frustration alors
quand arrive la période des entretiens
annuels sur la rémunération autant vous
dire que je ne suis pas du tout à l'aise
avec ce type de face à face chacun
défendant sa cause je demande donc à
l'équipe
et si on en parlait tous ensemble et
aussi incroyable que cela puisse
paraître ils ont accepté de parler
librement et collectivement de ce sujet
si tabou et nous voilà partis pendant
des heures et des heures à imaginer une
multitude de façons possibles de se
rémunérer jusqu'à arriver à leur
solution et cela reste sans doute notre
plus belle réussite est notre plus
grande preuve de confiance
au fait vous savez qui m'a aidé à
préparer ce talk
mon équipe bien sûr alors au début ils
ont plutôt rigoler mais ce sont eux qui
ont choisi ce qu'il était important de
partager avec vous ici
ensemble nous avons essayé de créer
l'entreprise dans laquelle chacun a
envie de travailler
celle qui ne confond pas objectifs et
résultats
celle où l'on oublie la tyrannie des
chiffres et du profit celle où l'on
préfère le plaisir la liberté et
l'épanouissement et vous de quelle
entreprise rêvez-vous merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]